-The President's allies
are flailing
as they try to defend him
in both the impeachment inquiry
and the controversy
over his decision
to abandon the Kurds.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
As he faces an intensifying
impeachment inquiry
in the House,
the President is also dealing
with nearly unanimous backlash
from both Republicans
and Democrats
over his decision to abandon
our Kurdish allies in Syria
who helped American soldiers
fight ISIS.
And, yet, even after being
accused of a tragic betrayal
by our Kurdish allies,
yesterday, Trump patted himself
on the back during a speech
in which he announced
that he was lifting sanctions
on Turkey.
-Today's announcement validates
our course of action...
with...Turkey...
that only a couple of weeks ago
was scorned,
and now people are saying, "Wow.
What a great outcome.
Congratulations."
-No one is saying that.
But if they did,
judging from your cadence,
they were super-high.
"Wow."
He sounds like
a local mattress salesman.
"Wow. What a great deal."
Second, any time Trump
says "people are saying,"
those people do not exist.
Trump uses "people are saying"
the same way guys use
"my friend has a problem"
when they ask their doctors
for Cialis.
Trump says he doesn't think
we should be fighting wars
in the Middle East,
but let's just be clear
about something --
Donald Trump has not
and has never been
an anti-war president.
He just pretends to be one.
All he cares about
is what you can do for him
personally.
And reporters who actually
talked to the Kurds
on the ground yesterday
confirmed that they definitely
were not saying, "Wow.
What a great outcome."
-They're not listening
to President Trump anymore.
He has totally
broken their trust.
They think that President Trump
has betrayed them
and that he is
effectively a joke,
that he doesn't keep his word.
The one people they did trust
was the United States,
but now U.S. troops
have been forced to leave.
They're seeing signs from
the Kurds saying, "We love you.
We still appreciate the role
that you, the U.S. troops, did,
but your president betrayed us."
-And that's what Trump does.
He betrays everybody.
It doesn't matter who you are
or what you do for him.
As soon as you're not useful
to him, he'll discard you.
I mean, just look
how many of his former aides
he's attacked
or thrown under the bus.
In fact, I'm pretty sure Steve
Bannon still lives under one.
And just take Rudy Giuliani,
Trump's personal lawyer
and perhaps his most vocal
and consistent defender.
After two of Rudy's associates,
Lev and Igor,
were arrested,
and it was reported --
that's their real names --
it was reported
that Rudy, himself, was under
criminal investigation,
here's what Trump had to say
about his longtime relationship
with his friend and ally.
-Is Rudy Giuliani still
your personal attorney?
-Well, I don't know.
I haven't spoken to Rudy.
I spoke to him
yesterday briefly.
He's a very good attorney.
And he has been my attorney.
Yeah, sure.
You know -- You know it's bad
when you keep changing tenses.
"Was he my lawyer? I don't know.
Is he?
I mean, yeah, he has been.
Will he be in the future?
Yeah. Sure."
But this is what Trump does.
The minute you're a burden
on him, he'll dump you.
In fact, now that Rudy is under
criminal investigation,
Trump makes him sit outside when
they fly on "Air Force One."
[ Laughter ]
Because Trump in his essence,
everything with him
is a transaction.
The Trump who betrays his allies
as soon as they're
no longer useful for him
is also the same guy
who tried to orchestrate
a corrupt quid pro quo
with Ukraine
for his own personal
political benefit.
This behavior is obviously
corrupt and illegal,
and we already have
all the evidence.
In fact, Trump and his aides
have basically confessed
to all of it.
So Republicans are running
out of ways to defend it.
For example, earlier this month,
Trump insisted
that Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell
had personally assured him
that his phone call
with the president of Ukraine,
in which he famously said
the words, "I would like you
to do us a favor," was perfect.
-I read Mitch McConnell's
statement yesterday,
and he read my phone call,
and as you know,
he put out a statement that said
that was the most innocent
phone call he's read.
And I spoke to him
about it, too.
He read my phone call with
the president of Ukraine,
Mitch McConnell. He said,
"That was the most innocent
phone call."
-Once again, he can't even mimic
actual human syntax
when he lies.
No human talks like that.
And for our purposes,
just go along with the idea
that Mitch McConnell is a human,
even though he is clearly
at least 60% dried apple doll.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, just imagine...
Just imagine...
if you can,
the most innocent phone call
you've ever witnessed.
You've never watched your spouse
order takeout and said,
"Wow, honey.
That was the most innocent
phone call I've ever seen.
You ordered that pizza
without murdering anyone."
But, still, Trump said
he spoke to McConnell
and McConnell told him
it was an innocent phone call.
There's just one problem.
McConnell doesn't seem
to remember it that way.
-The President has said that
you told him that his phone call
with the Ukrainian president
was perfect and innocent.
Do you believe
that the President
has handled this
Ukrainian situation perfectly?
-We've not had any conversations
on that subject.
-So he was lying about that?
-You'll have to ask him.
I don't recall any conversations
with the President
about that phone call.
-Wow. Even Mitch McConnell
won't back him up now.
By the end of this whole thing,
Republicans are just going to
start pretending they don't even
know who Donald Trump is.
"Uh, that man
was the president?
I just assumed he was
a Halloween decoration
meant to scare away pranksters
on mischief night."
Problem for the Republicans
is that the facts are so clear
that there's nothing they can
say or do to defend them.
For example, those words Trump
said on the phone call,
"I would like you
to do us a favor,"
would seem like a classic
quid pro quo, but this week,
Trump booster Sean Hannity
tried out a new,
even dumber defense.
"It's not a crime because
that's just how Trump talks."
-By the way,
it's important to remember
one more thing about
the President's phone call
with Ukraine,
and the President said,
"I'd like you to do us a favor."
Okay. It's a favor. Okay.
There were no strings attached.
Zero quid pro quo.
And let's be clear --
the term, "do us a favor,"
well, we all have go-to phrases.
You know.
I say "you know" a lot.
The President uses them
all the time.
-That's your argument?
That saying "do us a favor"
to a foreign leader
is equivalent to you saying
"you know"?
"You have to understand,
Trump says 'do us a favor'
the way Valley girls say 'like'
or how Jesse Pinkman
says 'bitch' all the time.
It doesn't mean he's a criminal.
That's just how he talks.
Also, he's a criminal."
Republicans
have also tried insisting
that there was no quid pro quo
because the "quo" in this case
would be the military aid
Trump was holding up,
and it would only be
a quid pro quo if Ukraine
knew that aid was being delayed.
Here's one
Republican Congressman
responding to shocking testimony
from a key witness
in the impeachment inquiry
this week on Fox News.
-Neither he or any other witness
has provided testimony that the
Ukrainians were aware that
military aid was being withheld.
You can't have a quid pro quo
with no "quo."
-That's how dumb these guys are.
They've gone from
"There was no quid pro quo"
to "There was a quid pro
but no 'quo.'"
Soon, they're going to try,
"There was a 'quid,'
and there was a 'quo,'
but we are definitely not pros."
But then that argument also --
[ Cheers and applause ]
It also fell through
when it was reported
that Ukraine did know
the aid was being held up.
So then Trump's allies tried
yet another new argument --
"it might have been wrong,
but it wasn't a crime."
Here's Trump's former acting
attorney general Matt Whitaker
making that argument on Fox News
this week.
Again, this is a man
who was in charge
of the Justice Department.
-I'm a former prosecutor,
and what I know
is this is a perfect time
for preliminary hearing
where you would say,
"Show us your evidence.
What evidence of a crime
do you have?"
I mean, the Constitution --
You know, sort of abuse of power
is not a crime.
-Yeah, it is.
Also, you look like
Abuse of Power
should be your wrestling name.
"Please welcome to the ring
Abuse of Power!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
"He's ripping up
the Constitution!"
So because they've totally
run out of arguments,
Republicans have now been
reduced to physically
obstructing
the impeachment inquiry.
For example, yesterday, we told
you that House Republicans
had orchestrated the dumb stunt
in which they held
a press conference
and then stormed into
a secure hearing room
in order to interfere
with the deposition.
The Congressman who led
the stunt, Matt Gaetz,
compared it to the movie "300."
Now, in case you forgot,
here's what that movie was like.
-This is Sparta!
-Okay, so now let's see those
Republicans storm the hearing
in the way they described
was like the movie "300."
-We're going to go and see
if we can get inside.
-Let's do it.
-So let's see if we can get in.
[ Laughter ]
-We're going in.
-"This is Sparta!
So..."
[ Laughter ]
That wasn't "300."
That was, like, "3."
Makes your publicity stunt
a lot less dramatic
when you have to shuffle along
like you're in a crowded mall
at Christmas.
Look at these guys. They all
look like they're headed
to the bathroom during an
intermission at a Broadway show.
So it turns out Trump, himself,
had advanced knowledge
of this stunt
and approved of it,
but it turns out the stunt
was even dumber than we thought
because a lot of those
Republicans were actually
allowed to be in the room
they were supposedly storming.
-A bunch of them made a big show
of storming the secure facility
in the Capitol where
impeachment investigators
are deposing witnesses.
We should note
that some of these folks
are on the committees
doing the investigating,
so they don't need to storm the
proceedings because some were
already allowed inside
and had been inside before.
-Guys, you can't "storm" a room
you're allowed to be in.
That's not storming.
That's entering.
You STORM
the beaches of Normandy.
You GO to the Jersey shore.
"We've taken
Point Pleasant, boys!"
Even Republicans
are having trouble defending
Trump's corrupt behavior now
because the facts are clear,
and support for impeachment
is rising in the polls.
If the House completes
its investigation
and officially impeaches Trump,
I bet at least a few Americans
will take a rip off a bong
and say...
-Wow. What a great outcome.
Congratulations.
-This has been "A Closer Look."